i didn't puke all of them oh you gotta
leave at least three more [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] knife in orderly
you [ __ ] muscle hamster
this show is presented by on it
the church of what's happening now
is brought to you by ziprecruiter
the new year means a fresh start for
your business and a great year starts
with great making great hires
our listeners can post jobs on
ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com church that's
ziprecruiter.com
church
ziprecruiter.com
church
the show is also brought to you by lyft
go to lift.lyft is where drivers can
make up to 35 an hour and getting
started is just a tap away sign up today
at lyft.com joey sign up today to drive
for lift at lyft.com
sorry
oh [ __ ] kick that mule [ __ ] it's
all over 2017 the restraining order's
over it's over
[Music]
we're kicking this mule with theo vaughn
my nephew lee syed
and your uncle [ __ ] joey kick
it lee
blast the [ __ ] speakers i want the
speakers to blow up please i want to see
somebody's balls blow off their body bro
i want to see my dick try to [ __ ] my ass
bro
let's party
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
happy new year to you and yours
i hope this is a happy year for you i
hope you're healthy because if you ain't
healthy you can't get your dick sucked
and you cannot make any either you
understand me you can't hug your kids so
uh my number one my one of my favorite
people in this [ __ ] city
is on the show tonight theo vaughn
my little [ __ ] jewish nephew already
started the new year off
puking the edibles tonight i don't know
you know what happened you know you know
what happened bro you know what happened
[ __ ] little money away from me for a
week and you didn't keep up the training
okay first of all i don't want to hear a
story i don't want to explain i know
exactly what happened
10 years you've never puked around me
except that one night the acid but then
we went deep i even burped in my own
mouth
wow you know what i'm saying you really
yeah you rip a little mushroom you're
pissing awesome burp and a little bit of
belly come on a little bit of [ __ ]
yellow acidic fluid
but it keeps you tight we're going four
or five hours that night late i took you
to i took you to [ __ ] seal training
that night i had you going under [ __ ]
barbed wire and [ __ ] that was something
that i felt horrible about but tonight
you didn't even let the medication hit
you in you [ __ ] those chocolate la
luna is but you told me you bought four
of them and took them down a long time i
did you can see i have video evidence
that's why this is why
did you eat the whole thing of course i
did what do you mean eat the whole eat
it off camera do magician tricks
i never do it i used to have to watch
him he would put he's a jew if you got
those fingers they move real best
magicians
not a big living oh they keep ten
percent of their children
oh yeah they invented the [ __ ]
magician yeah [ __ ] jews that's who
invented the magician
yeah they're all magicians out of the
womb bro
man yeah last time i saw lee was over
here squealing on the path
[ __ ] up
and the craziest part about that joey
was
when i came in i thought i heard it i'm
like there's kind of a squealing in the
microphone at first and lee's like i'll
fix it and by the end it was him
it was it was like
look like a [ __ ] disabled gerbil bro
[ __ ] that's how i felt that was like
the the deepest i've ever been on muscle
he looked like a damn welfare gerbil he
was over here
it was chocolate mushrooms that smelled
like parmesan cheese
he was eating it and it was foaming out
of his mouth
i just put it in my mouth and drank it i
didn't deal with it he wants to [ __ ]
chew it he wants a snack he thinks it's
anthony bourdain you gotta swallow them
drugs dog you can't be [ __ ] that's
what i tried to do tonight and that's
why i puked up all over the floor
because you said you were making fun of
me you're like just swallow that
[ __ ] thing
and it was like still a whole chunk and
my body just is like i think my body is
starting to fight back because i wasn't
getting that [ __ ] up over the weekend
because you do them every night and you
do little amounts you gotta go deep
you gotta get into 16 1800 by yourself
yeah you got to get your vowels hardly i
ain't eight hundred they don't do
nothing for nobody yeah that's an
appetizer in your world first of all you
know i was doing over a thousand no you
weren't i wasn't i know you you gotta
get your bowels high bro i want to
[ __ ] i'm gonna i want your [ __ ] to be
scared that's how high you gotta get
it's so funny we were having a
conversation before the podcast started
about
you know about this is it like
i guarantee there's a lot of people
today walking around
with an ice pack on their head going
what the [ __ ] happened two nights ago
yeah like i went out to get two drinks i
ended up blowing four guys
my [ __ ] shut you know you don't you
don't know what realm you get into you
know and uh
when we spoke today right off the bat
you're like listen dawg i'm trying to
keep my life together i'm a young dude
i'm good looking i don't want to fade
away so i've been behaving myself was
your main thing
alcohol and then you went crazy yeah i
mean well i just ended up getting key
you know like i ended up getting into
drugs usually sometimes at night but
drugs without the alcohol or they have
alcohol how to soften you up first
i think i would just
you know that's a good question man
alcohol was never never been a thing for
me i never cared about alcohol i just
once people started
having cocaine around i just kind of
like the smell of it you know what i'm
saying bro what about meth nothing else
oh no nothing like that dude we used to
do like uh back in the day some dude
came through the neighborhood i remember
with some kind of uh
i don't know what lsd suppository some
kind of suppositories dude people were
doing
yeah do it was like just do you know
putting these like little
they were kind of uh i don't want to say
pink they were kind of reddish looking
little
[ __ ] throwing rainbow treats up yeah
it's not manly enough if it's pink i
mean it was yeah and people was doing ls
these lsd supply stores this dude had
about i remember he probably had about
400 of them i don't know where he got
him from germany or somewhere iceland or
something you know and to us that was
like they got him from saturn you know
we never even heard of that germany you
know we'll [ __ ] do this and people
were doing acid you know or ella
whatever it was doing the suppositories
i remember for a while so i like
psychedelics a little bit when i was
younger uh
and what else dude and then but out here
i don't know what happened i just had a
couple of crazy nights and then uh i was
like i'm gonna try something different
man so i just decided i'm gonna stop
partying
so now i've got about six months i've
been sober since i'm well last time i
walked out of here i went over to the
improv and did a set high on mushrooms
and they were flicking the lights on
stage
i still have it on video man i'll put it
out i'll put it out for you uh
for your legion how old are you now
36 man i'm an adult it's tough to
say to yourself this is it you know you
have those nights and like we were
saying you had a a spectacular night
in my world like where i came from
that's a spectacular night oh yeah
getting in a cab
going for a blow
uh then the the guy hooks you up with a
chick you [ __ ] the chick in the cab no
he did oh he [ __ ] her in the cab oh no
no this is craziness now what time did
this night end
dude so what happened with that night
was let me revamp it for you so what
happened was i went to a party bro i
don't even plan on drinking no you're in
new york i'm in new york city yeah i'm
in new york city yup i was doing comedy
i had a sublet there i was just kind of
experiencing the city we talked once or
twice when i was there you know and i
was enjoying it man it was good
and then i got i went to a party one
night and afterwards they and they were
drinking at the party
and uh and i just felt uncomfortable
dude to be honest man most of my life i
have felt uncomfortable bro i don't know
what it is like in a lot of environments
i just feel
uncomfortable out of place out of place
yeah yeah yeah you feel that ever oh all
the time what do you mean ever there's
there's like there's more times that i
feel
in place like that like that that's the
weird times but it's like
my girlfriend and i were just talking
about it because
we stayed in on new year's eve yeah but
seeing the shots of times square and
seeing the shots of the clubs
maybe i should have done something a
little bit more social but that's that
is not i would i would rather i'd rather
be in a box than in a club yeah it's
that that would feel so uncomfortable
there like a new year's eve like club
like that's not me at all well you don't
see in the club too they show you the
pitch you don't see people getting
[ __ ] molested in the background and
people you know
but at least light a candle or something
for you later you do anything oh well
yeah we
he's gonna joey's gonna make fun of me
we went away the weekend before we went
to long beach as funny as the time
they took a trip to long beach i don't
know probably to pick up rent right this
is amazing this is just amazing
so anyway bro i can't even get away that
was it you took your girl to [ __ ] no
she took me she took me jesus christ but
then we just decided to come home
because we
because it was raining yeah we're gonna
sit in someone else's apartment on new
year's eve down in long beach when i
have a nicer apartment up here
what the [ __ ] it's a horror show i tried
and i keep it it sounds like they're not
losing them by the month it sounds like
the notes
on down syndrome no no this was
something that when he told me i go what
now when he told me i thought they were
going to leave
friday night
go to a hotel like normal americans
right yeah wake up in the morning get a
little room service gives her a stab and
yeah take a walk down come back smoke a
joint eat a stall maybe about six take
it to a nice [ __ ] restaurant six
seven o'clock sitting dog so you're out
of there by 9 30 you take him back to
the apartment give him straight up eat
three more stars and watch some stupid
movie i thought that's what he was doing
america i got a call from him thursday
at lunchtime so yeah yeah we're about to
leave i go leave where
long beach i i almost shot myself in the
[ __ ] head i go this kid can't be this
stupid and then that night i went to
dinner
i had to do a set
last week
and
i had two hours to kill
i said i told my don't even make dinner
i'm gonna eat dinner in hollywood
there's no sense of me coming back yeah
i did a set for penn state
so i had two when i was a kid so i went
to chibo
that's one of my favorite places is it a
good place i've never even been there i
see it i don't eat the pizza i don't
even know that [ __ ] i get the salad it's
delicious the the minute
whatever salad and the big mama
spaghetti with no meat just pasta with
sauce and you've got cheese
isn't it give you a small serving it's
always been good i've been eating there
for [ __ ] years wow and that's what i
eat i go there three times a year though
if i'm lucky i got three times to drive
by i got an hour here yeah i got an
audition i planned it i go okay i got an
hour and a half i might as well go to
the [ __ ] keyboard and i get excited
yeah
i sit next to a guy i go to the bar and
i see the bartender he's an old door guy
from the improv we start chit chatting
two things down for me is a guy from
emerson college
and right away i gotta ask him i had to
ask him what do they teach you up there
because i never got the members in
college
and i don't know i'm not sure anymore i
go i hired him because i thought he was
sharper than i was but lately he's been
slipping i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on
and that was lee that was lee i went to
long beach thursday afternoon
for new year's now i can see like i said
friday after all the traffic is the nah
here's the best one
here's the best one out of all of them
i call him thursday night or he calls me
we're talking and the conversation he
goes yeah we are being beat
i go you're not even in a [ __ ] hotel
with like a [ __ ] elliptical that you
go to the elliptical you've been home
all week with her and now you go down
there for two more [ __ ] nights with
her to do nothing to look at each other
and eat cookies and [ __ ] at a stranger's
apartment watch really bad tv in a
stranger's apartment this was something
that i was like waters bro i don't know
like [ __ ] squatters when he called me
sadly and told me he was coming back
i wanted to tell him just gps to cartoon
with the ocean
to the santa monica pier and take the
car right off the [ __ ] pier then
because it ain't getting no better in
your life he went away to long beach and
every morning when i woke up since that
today there was a burglary in long beach
where the guy shot the burglar he shot
the burglar every day i woke up and then
that morning all i was waiting for you
were praying for it to be like lisa no
like to see lee [ __ ] shot in the head
like lee got hit by a car coming with a
box of wings
they got poor girlfriend on the thing i
don't know what happened the guy didn't
stop for the red light the saddest part
is who the [ __ ] goes to long beach i
don't know okay lee used to treat
himself to a nice night at chibo at the
bar
and now a few years later he's finally
got a girl no that wasn't me that was he
was at cheebo that night and he was
thinking about me yeah that was some
reminiscent i had to ask him what did he
teach you that
they teach you anything what the [ __ ] do
you have to eat there i'll be honest
okay this was a
we we don't have we couldn't fly
anywhere we didn't have enough time so
this is what you chose
but we have we actually had a good time
the [ __ ] aquarium and queen mary are
[ __ ] awesome when you're stoned as
[ __ ] oh but this is what i will i did
want to talk to you guys about it you
see what i gotta deal with airbnb the
aquarium is you you're out it feels like
squat like it was the weirdest
experience of my life they let you touch
any animals like at the pet and zoo in
there
uh yeah well at the aquarium yeah but at
the uh i thought i thought you were
talking about the apartment for a second
i'm not at the airbnb dude you [ __ ]
like that another roommate like there's
roaches in the apartment massage and
other roommates no thank god there
weren't roommates
this guy
imagine if there was a roommate he takes
his lady out
no no it was like a horror show yeah i
live
i live in a [ __ ] world between him
and my wife
i'm not gonna make it to 56.
i'm not gonna make it to i just spent
four weeks in that house with my wife
wow it's a torture chamber
it's a [ __ ] house of horrors
i love it with all my heart it's a
torture chamber what's the worst part
like what's the worst part
honestly it'd be 9 30
in the morning at night
and just sitting there not having a spot
because
i don't want to be at the store every
night yeah you know i don't want to be
that guy you don't need to be at the
store every night there's young guys
coming up i know how i felt when i was
coming up and i had [ __ ] to do and
there's some old guy that's coming down
i'm good enough two spots a week i'm
good this week i'm doing thursday
talking about tom tomorrow now do
flappers
if i get out jiu-jitsu early wednesday
i'll pop into some place but you know i
got a gig friday i'm [ __ ] good i'm
not working on nothing nothing i'm just
putting a couple bits together finding
my new [ __ ] voice you know yeah
it's like uh
when you travel it breaks the monotony
up a little bit oh yeah and it was i was
home for four [ __ ] weeks and it was
the holidays and one of those weeks the
baby was home
that's tough babies off of school all
week one week vacation
and it rained three of those days you
know what i'm saying so
she wanted to ride the bicycle that's
like a triple threat of so do parents
hate the truth of the matter is the
truth of the matter is that my
i'm a dud
i've always been a dud you know lee
says that he feels uncomfortable up
i tell you what i where i feel
comfortable
feel comfortable in a bar where the
bartender's
a good-looking woman in 1924 yeah
she still has tits she wears push-up
brush she's got freckles on her tits
she's got a sense of humor
the boss eats 20 she serves some [ __ ]
food in there that's kick ass there's a
jukebox there's music you know what at
this age i don't want a [ __ ] pool
table yeah and i don't want a dark board
i don't want a lot of movement i never
like movement yeah sit down and have a
[ __ ] bee and talk to me if you want
to do this if you're going to be moving
around go somewhere else
and arguments and i can't walk this
guy's throwing a [ __ ] dot at me
you know i i i just want to be what i'm
saying like that's what i want to do
that's my ideal ball and to be strictly
honest with you since the age of 16 that
was always my ideal bar
once we started going out to those
discos i've said it once i've said it
before my wife asked me on the ride home
the other day from dinner we were
listening to studio 54
on uh sirius xm and she goes so you used
to go disco dancing are you crazy i was
a kid when that [ __ ] came out yeah i go
when i was in high school
i could put a handful of times i went to
clubs with the studio but i went to
studio in 84. there was nothing going on
in the studio no more it was a thursday
night 84. yeah i was going to club area
like twice
i went to like the rooftop four five six
times but i was never a club guy bro
look at me i knew who the [ __ ] i was i
belong to the neighborhood bar with a
bartender named lila yeah she had a dog
behind the bar the dog slept the whole
[ __ ] time now that's the bar i grew
up in john mary's they had a little
circular biscuit thing like a daily like
a a bakery thing in the middle and it
would have a cover and in the middle
there was ham and cheese sandwiches
that's beautiful
so if you want a sandwich you just went
over and got it they had steward
sandwiches and next to it was a uh not
don't cook tonight called chicken
delight it was a chickafil
not chick-fil-a this is when chicken was
chicken and one of the kids we hung with
was the [ __ ] cook
so at the end of the shift he come over
to the bar with a box of chicken from
the leftover chicken beautiful [ __ ]
night it was and you had a tab
and the guy that ran the place was a
loan sharks
they had to buy an eight ball you could
borrow 300 from on the spot i still own
8 000. 1980 [ __ ] two
uh you know i never thought i never
the first time i went to vegas dog i
knew it wasn't for me yeah i just always
felt very insecure in those places
always still do yeah that's how i still
do and i always had an excuse in my head
on why i felt insecure
when i was younger it was that
i wasn't good looking enough and i'm a
criminal these people are all nice
people
these are the environment i want to hang
with these people don't want to hang
with me yeah and when i got to a certain
age it was i was too old
and then now i'm like i just feel like
i'm playing out [ __ ] pervert yeah
like i remember being 25 and seeing like
50 year old guys
thinking why is this [ __ ] guy here
this is a perfect lee
it's a sweetheart i've seen leather bar
no i could tell he's a gentleman lee
wants to go to a bar and watch a
football game and have a bucket of wings
and he wants to yell maybe a little bit
he doesn't want nobody close to him
yelling he doesn't want nobody
leo paid three dollars extra
just to um yeah to sit in the white
section
wouldn't do good in studio 54
what's he going to do have one drink
people are trying to talk to him i never
liked going to a place where the music
was loud that's where you lose uncle
joey yeah if i can't talk to you the way
we're talking i don't want to i'm lost
i'm lost you know yeah see that's the
same as for me man but i would for some
reason i kept making excuses that made
me like
less than you know so like oh it's my
fault that i don't fit in here instead
of just being like oh this is in my
environment you know now why didn't you
feel it was your you're an environment i
just felt like you were older no i felt
like uh
you know like these people were rich or
these people were better than me or
these people
you know i'm
you know i'm kind of a
a
a bit of a miscreant you know i grew up
on the other side of the tracks and
these people but they don't know like
that's the thing i always thought
because my my whole thing comes from
like i've always been chubby and short
short you're like a tall in shape good
looking dude i'd look at you and i think
there's nothing wrong in his life at all
like there's no way he's self-conscious
about anything
well
that's
wrong man i look at you and i think this
guy's [ __ ] what environment got it
all what an environment do you feel
comfortable in
just a more real environment a more just
calm uh just another people 50 people
100 people
yeah as long as yeah i can feel okay in
10 50. when it gets uh to be a little
more than that sometimes it's just too
much but when the music's loud and i
can't communicate with people then
that's where i start to feel
uncomfortable that's my end that's my
fault but i kept going back i kept
thinking there was something wrong with
me that the environment was okay but it
wasn't man and that's what happened that
night i went to this club
and uh they had a party for my friend's
fashion line
and
then i got in this taxi after this girl
gets in with me i left early because i
was going to be on opie and jim norton
that's when opie and jim were still
together
and uh this beautiful girl gets in the
taxi with me this asian girl
and she just started talking about the
night she said that she had fun at the
party but that her boyfriend wasn't in
town
then she goes her boyfriend's never in
town then she's like what happens in
taxis stays in taxis right that's what
she said so i'm thinking
[ __ ] yeah you know like
she wants me to make a move on or try to
make a move shut me down
and i don't know if that's what made me
feel weird after that or whatever but
the taxi dropped her off after that
and uh and it was just me and the driver
bruh and this dude spoke another
language you know something
[ __ ] fancy you know something could
play soccer you know like this dude
like this dude was betting on [ __ ]
foreign soccer games on his phone for
sure you know
and uh he said i thought he said drugs
dude and i just said cocaine that's what
i said and next you know we're in north
harlem
um he bought some cocaine for us
he comes back in the car
we're doing cocaine
and then he's like i got a gift for you
i got a gift you know and i thought it
was gonna be you know i grew up in like
a troubled area i thought it was gonna
be his dick you know like i'm you know
that's what i was expecting anyway
and uh
and then a hook a prostitute knocks on
the door you know
this lady gets in and i think it was a
man honestly in hindsight she had these
big sunglasses on
kind of a man's face that was under the
sunglasses you have cocktails in you at
this point yeah a couple tequilas dude
and uh so now we're partying bruh me and
me and the driver were first partying
for about an hour
dude i got so high i remember thinking
where is the driver that's how [ __ ] i
was
and he was sitting next to me doing
cocaine yeah at what point does this
become not a taxicab ride like when does
the meter get turned off like this oh
the meter's going bro the meter's at
about 270 bro no so he's gotta [ __ ]
be positive because i'm paying for this
experience bro
so then dude
this hooker gets in
she has she had kind of long hair
huge sunglasses covered about 60 percent
of her face
and the 40 of her face you you could see
to me look like a man's face right
like i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with that i'm just like if i were
on a game show and it was like guess
forty percent of this person's face i
would have guessed man first right you
know what i'm saying like look like a
man's face you know
or it looked like a woman had just
shaved recently that's what it looked
like you know oh so anyway we're all
we're all getting high together and the
hooker starts making advances towards me
brother sounds ridiculous
and i got out of the car man i felt
uncomfortable dude
so then do you like sliding you
understand in my world i'm thinking
you're a louisiana boy
in [ __ ] harlem
no [ __ ] do you feel out of place i feel
out of place that no i always felt
comfortable in north harlem yeah
like that's i know that neighborhood
where you're at you know what i'm saying
you're not in the bronx yet
right you're not there yeah i don't know
where we're at oh yeah it doesn't matter
was it dark it was a dark dark that's
all that matters yeah you're only having
a good time if you're not in a dark
neighborhood
i was raising one i know when oh my god
you know i know when i'm back now what
time is all this going down it's about 3
30.
all right so what's up so you walk out
of the cab where are you now you getting
another cab no i'm in the street luigi
comes out after me that's the dude i was
partying with the driver
and dude you know what's crazy is he had
even one of the lights on the taxi
wouldn't go off and he made like this
little paper mache thing and put it over
the light bro like this dude was
i mean i don't think he was homosexual
but this dude was about the most
romantic [ __ ] cab driver i've ever
spent time with dude and dude it was
more romantic in that taxi than it was
at your [ __ ] airbnb that's the
saddest part
so dude i get out he comes out after me
he made me give him 100 bucks right and
i gave him the hunter because i was a
little scared at this point
and i'm thinking he's going to pay the
hooker and she'll go
but then i look back over there a couple
minutes later a minute later
um
and they're kissing on each other's
necks he's spending 100 with this hooker
dude he [ __ ] just got this hundred
out of me
wait so your taxi driver bullied you
into buying him a hooker no he owe him
money anyway
but right away he took the money luigi
took the money and said hold on five
minutes
let me go get twenty dollars worth off
this hook up he took that money and
reinvested it in the neighborhood you
know what i'm saying
and look i respect hookers man like you
know i've been through some tough nights
man not in [ __ ] north harlem but
still man i don't give a [ __ ] well
here's i respect women that are out
there if they got to be out there
selling their body i don't have nothing
against that i know you don't but in
north harlem you ain't getting into
nothing good you understand me keep
saying north harlem are they
i don't know i don't know like east
harlem listen all i know is north i used
to go to holland to buy coke and i'd see
women out there
and dog let me tell you something it's
an illusion yeah it's an illusion
first of all four out of ten of them got
bigger dicks than you oh damn four four
out of ten of those chicks we don't like
those in those days
it was you gotta remember up in harlem
in those days the bronx it was
open [ __ ] corral then the 90s the
russians came oh yeah and i never saw it
but i had friends tell me you go to
queens and they'd be six foot russian
blondes with leopard mini skirts
that you give them 300 just to eat the
[ __ ] they were that wow hot banging
banging like they took over so all the
other ones the crack hoes disappeared
yeah all that you know but it knows that
even when i was when i got in trouble
with my buddy you know dodger and we
were going over there those hookers
yeah
those city racks
days you had a that that takes a certain
nerve yeah a lot of them work at the
popeyes during the daytime no they don't
work they they're at the clinic
getting blood transfusions dude we used
to have this lady victoria miss victoria
in our neighborhood bro you could pull
up bro
you could eat her ass for like 40 bucks
right she'd sit in your car window dude
just basically put her ass in your
[ __ ] car window
like a [ __ ] to-go box you know
you could if you had somebody driving
you could even have them drive the block
and she would just sit in there like a
little side item bro
but so this dude get luigi i give him
the 100 he gets back in the car
they're making out i'm kind of pissed
dude but i don't want to bring that
negative energy back into the car
right
so i deal with my feelings out in the
street for a minute kind of process
through that
why don't you want to bring negative
feelings back into the car just because
i'm already really extremely high man
i'm under the influence of cocaine um
it's almost 4 a.m
uh and i don't know these people that
well and i still need to get home and
for some reason at this point i feel
like luigi is responsible to get me home
right
so i get back in the front seat right
and they're hooking up in the back a
little [ __ ] like it's getting real
it's getting wild you know uh
and i want to still do cocaine you know
so but i don't want to interrupt him
dude so i remember trying to quietly do
cocaine in the front see just like okay
like
like
like the softest little inhale you could
do were you watching them at any point
i was definitely listening hard you know
i mean uh no cologne
all you smell is like cologne like when
you walk in the middle of them all you
smells like [ __ ]
heavy duty perfume
she smelled like violence to me in
tattoos she was a tough lady or man i
mean i thought she was a man the face
looked like a man's face to me but she
had big sunglasses on she could have
been one of those taller vietnamese
people that kind of look black at night
you know
ah
so we're in there and uh now i'm in the
car and i'm trying to quietly do cocaine
dude like just like a [ __ ] just like
a
like just doing it in like an
installment it's like how to bump on
layaway why do you know just like
they're back there [ __ ] why can't you
just because there's something wrong
with me where i sacrifice other people
like i just feel like i got to be
considerate at all times i don't want to
interrupt them dude
i guess i don't know man i was [ __ ] up
bro so they're partying at one point i
remember even turning my head back and
just dumping cocaine quietly into the
top of my nose like this
just like just as quiet as i could be
and a cop goes by dude cop goes by i get
scared
i tell luigi i'm scared bro he don't you
don't give a [ __ ] dude that's when i
realized like he didn't care about me as
much as i cared about him i guess
and he's like you drive you drive and
that's when i got in the driver's seat
and i drove man i drove us
i drove us about a mile and a half dude
i don't know where i was dude and uh
and then i pulled over because a voice
in my head bro
first a voice in my head is like dude at
least you're it was like you're out here
bro you're high
you know you're doing cocaine
uh but at least you're making money you
know like i was working like i was the
cab driver
and that's like dude my brain's [ __ ]
up like this ain't my cab you know i got
to pay for this
and then my brain was like you don't
have a commercial driver's license
that's what got me to pull over dude
that technicality that if a cop stopped
me that i wouldn't have one and i pulled
over i got another taxi got back to my
hotel room finished doing my cocaine
and i had to be on opi and jim norton
that morning
and it's 5 30 now dude i took three
showers bruh in 10 minutes
right i have one question yeah did you
pay luigi or did you just kind of get
out and just get into another camp we
ended up in a little bit of an argument
at the end
i left a hundred dollars on the car seat
and yelled adios had him really loud i
don't even know if he spoke spanish dude
i'm just screaming adios
i'm in this [ __ ] hooker
who had the smallest hits i've ever seen
bro look like a man's chest
but uh
then i go to opium gym dude and the
other guest for the day is daryl
strawberry
and i could not even feel my face dude i
couldn't even think
uh
and that's when i was like this is bad
luck you know i couldn't even talk they
were asking me questions dude and i'm
just
i couldn't even
like that i couldn't feel my face i
could all my thoughts was coming out of
my neck
like i was running on on neck thoughts
dude i'm [ __ ] thinking with my neck
bro
so i [ __ ]
sat there for three hours bro
just roasting
now i know how you feel kind of late
i just sat there just
just boiling in my own [ __ ] drug
induced [ __ ]
and then i [ __ ] laughed
and i'm halfway there halfway on the
walk over there i realized i had on
[ __ ]
sweatpants with jeans over them bro
horrible
that's like a catheter outfit like if
you might be getting a catheter and you
might have to stay overnight
i feel while i'm sitting here because
i'm like you know
just people like leah he's a sweetheart
i wish to god lee never does a drug
he would never do a drug
but
for some people some experiences like
that experience yeah
to wake up and unhope because you
basically woke up on opium jimmy
and you're coming down off the juice
you're not paranoid but you can't talk
either you're in this scare yeah
you're in that stage you're [ __ ] uh
[Music]
why the [ __ ] am i even here it's
horrible yeah i'm sitting here going i
remember doing that 10 000 times oh
not not you know being in a cab with a
hooker but i when you said harlem
when i was growing up i had a friend and
he had a girlfriend he was about
seven years old and he's dead now he got
rested so
but he had a girlfriend dog who was
[ __ ] banging wow and i saw her naked
once when i was like 18. that [ __ ]
stayed with me
that was jerk off material for like six
months
i go ahead i disappear i do my thing
i go to colorado i do a little time
i'm back in jersey in 90 [ __ ] three
and i reconnect with a friend of mine
and he goes what are you doing tonight
i'm not what do you want to do let's go
let's go out
meet me at t-neck at this i forget the
name of the place it's a popular place
for that age group you know and i went
there and met them about p-neck yeah
tina tenofly there's a t-neck t-neck
it's uh
artist cafe something like that
something like very chic so a lot of
kids from my neighbor thought you know
as they got older they went there for a
few drinks i was at this time i'm
31 years old
i'm doing comedy i'm doing comedy
already uh uh i'm not getting nowhere
with it you know what i'm saying i'm not
knocking down no doors and [ __ ] but i'm
doing [ __ ] comedy
and i hook up with them and at the time
i'm a [ __ ] fiend you know it's 35 a
gram
on 178th street
25 if you want to clean him
i'd go in and get three right off the
bat jack
bam this [ __ ] was glass
on aluminum foil and they'd give you a
blast when you walked in that's
beautiful they sat you down they go what
do you want to do and you go i don't
know let me taste the 35 and then what
do you want to do you want to taste 25
and i you go there and then you just
they walk you out to the door and you'd
walk back to your car and the cops were
paid for and you
it put your back out on uh not amsterdam
but one of those streets under the
bridge yeah and then rule number one you
took the lincoln tunnel back go into get
a [ __ ] hot dog roll a joint
these idiots that would get back on the
george washington bridge they had
spotters right they just seen you go
over they'd pull you over now they
confiscate your [ __ ] car you have to
give it to them because they're not
they're gonna bring the dog and they're
gonna get you anywhere right so don't
[ __ ] with them
it was hardcore damn
so i went over there first that was my
that was my automatic first stop of the
night and i had it down to a science in
those days sometimes i'd walk over and
take the bus back
same difference
what are we gonna say he'd be high on
that bus though huh no i wouldn't do it
oh yeah wait to get home no i'd do that
little blast that he'd give me by the
time i got to the bus i'd be coming down
like a little bit like
but how theo was saying that he felt
uncomfortable there his first time
do you remember how you felt the first
couple times you went there before you
it became old hat like were you freaked
out or were you visit already at that
point
since my mom had a dry cleaner in the
bronx probably in your system yes and my
mom had a bar in union city and my mom
had a bar in harlem at a young age
it's in my system yeah i had a friend of
mine to take me over once to the city
and when i got back in the car he goes
it's amazing how you blended right in
he goes you knew the walk i knew those
first you know those first 10 years of
my life i lived in new york city those
first seven years of my life in this
country yeah i lived in new york city i
went to school in the heart of new york
city yeah i went to school on 89th
street bs 166
from k1 to [ __ ] third grade then i
went to captain school in jersey but all
that time i got the patois of the city
yeah my mom's action was 125th my
santeria action was on 148th
i knew the [ __ ] city you understand
me that i got older and i knew george
washington bridge i knew the [ __ ]
streets my step dad shot a dude on 148th
street right there the santeria party i
knew the escape route i knew a way to
drop the gun on riverside drive i knew
that situation
so
i i get the coke i go back to jersey i
meet him and in those days dog
i'm not a big drinker but i'm the type
of guy see
i'll call you up and go what are you
doing tonight theo now let's go get a
drink and the way that you go joey i got
an audition tomorrow dog don't even
start your [ __ ] tonight
come on bro i wouldn't invite you for a
drink i got a joint in my pocket we go
we have one drink we have two drinks we
have three drinks awesome that chick
used to [ __ ] shows up
and with her friend that sucked my dick
in the bathroom that time it will
compadre right
it's 9 30 it's early feel let's get a
taste no bro i got that big audition on
abc [ __ ] give theo 10 more minutes
i'll get the chick to buy him another
[ __ ] double kamikaze then he'll be
begging me for a blast
and that's
right there that would break me down
yeah i went out with the intention and
you know how i got a good like i'm
pretty good when i tell you listen we
got to do [ __ ] tomorrow i'm pretty good
about it
towards the end i wasn't good at all i
would snort an hour before a [ __ ]
audition
yeah
i got thrown out of an audition on fox
one time towards the end
towards 2006 dog after the longest shot
i got a little [ __ ] weird yeah
yeah yeah yeah and one day
i get this audition directly from fox
like they're like we want you to read
for this role yeah
you know it's been done before the crazy
roommate owes the bookie money
right now his mom supports him he can't
get a job as in shame and they were
looking for artie lange
yeah all right
and i'll never forget my [ __ ] coked
up
ready to quit mine i said you know what
they're looking for this guy
i might as well go in there like this
guy
so i did something i never did a day
before i stopped shaving oh i thought
you glued hair to you no what do you
think i'm [ __ ] half a [ __ ] mook i
don't know dude we used to glue hair to
our face to make beards pubic hair too
during halloween stop
some of it was gray you know
i didn't put gel in my hair i just put
water in my hair and i [ __ ] went in
there
like um
like two hours after doing coke
and i went in front of the camera was
the casting director me and a camera bro
and after the first reach you'll stop
because i think you better go home
i'm gonna make believe this never
happened really yeah she knew you were
high yeah how did she know she must have
been grammed up occasionally yeah yeah
yeah i could tell but it was very
disrespectful
she never said a word wow she never
called
the agent at the time and said hey this
kid was [ __ ] up
i hit him i hit on an asian lady
recently he was cast in the casting
director and she tore a manager on me
really yeah i get back home and he's
like she said you did a pretty good job
but she said he was hitting on her the
whole time what's casting it i don't
even remember it's beautiful though too
down down
on the south side i don't know oh this
is the west side uh no this was in uh
out here in burbank somewhere okay
they used to be an asian girl in an
office here
that was something out of a [ __ ]
movie yeah she used to cast
on the west side her and her partner
used to have a cat and the partner was
no [ __ ] slouch either
i walked in that one that was like jesus
[ __ ] christ what's going on with
these casting directors yeah
i don't know where she is now but it's
probably the same one this girl was
stunning i i didn't mean to hit on i was
just being a natural man you know like i
can't help it like oh what's offensive
and i wasn't saying anything like you
know
touching my crotch or anything like that
you know it's probably just saying oh
you look nice today or something like
that you know like i can't help it if i
got a little fervor in my voice for a
woman you know they act like that's a
sin out here these days you know oh you
want to bust a nut on a lady you're a
[ __ ] you know you're a deviant you
know you're you're charles manson if you
want to do that you know charles manson
studies scientologists he's still saudi
scientologists how crazy is that [ __ ]
he's a little [ __ ] dude i beat that
dude's ass
i swear to god you let that dude out for
one minute in a [ __ ] used car lot
i'll beat that [ __ ] dude's
ass bro
i don't hate charles manson so much
because he's a [ __ ] dude he made other
people he made hot chicks go out and
kill people i mean it's kind of romantic
and [ __ ] but
at the same time he's a [ __ ] let me
tell you something as a child i read
that book and that book [ __ ] me up did
it really when i was about 13 and when i
after i got left back it really [ __ ]
with me
because i wasn't left back material i
just got caught up in some [ __ ]
fantasy world yeah
but that teacher mr king mo
who was a [ __ ] prick he left you back
yeah he left me back no i left myself
back i had summer school
but i went to summer school i did the
same [ __ ] if you have three misses in
summer school
you're done you know i [ __ ] missed
three classes over this chick because
that's the only time i get together with
it
first three joey missed the first three
i was in love dawg i didn't give a [ __ ]
a young lover and i thought that my dog
was gonna just say pass them to the
eighth grade nah they held me back
it was [ __ ] brutal it [ __ ] with me
it [ __ ] with everything i had so mr
king law is part of uh every month you
had to do a book report for him
the only problem was was an oral book
report
so he would take the book and dissect it
at that time man i was so pissed off in
myself yeah he was still my english
teacher
even though i got put in mr barone's
class
who mr baroon i took him to the premiere
of the of the grudge match wow that's
how tight i am with baron that's
beautiful no no no baron was tight but
here is the beauty of it
me and barone hated each other in the
seventh grade like he kept telling me in
the hallways you better not get left
back because you're gonna get me next
year it's gonna be all over
and so that [ __ ] uh
last day of school
if you have to go to eighth grade you go
to eighth grade you have to go to summer
school they just put you in the other
seventh grade class
so the whole [ __ ] eight hours baron
kept busting my balls it's going to be
fun you sitting here all next year i'm
going to fail you again you're going to
be in the 7th grade to your 90's
because you're going to be driving the
other kids to school
he would torment me so he tormented me
dog for like four or five hours
and on the way out of the classroom i
saw his keys around the desk
i took his [ __ ] car keys
and i walked home and i threw him in the
[ __ ] weed somewhere some [ __ ]
and about an hour later he pulls up my
house with a cab where's my [ __ ] keys
wow
and we didn't talk again and the next
day i got i got left back
and i was in this classroom where he
never mentioned it ever again that's
pretty cool of them and after about two
months we became tight because i
realized he was a good basketball player
and [ __ ]
so
how the [ __ ] why don't we end up talking
about this [ __ ] weirdest dude mr larry
we had his black kid in our school mr
larry he got held back
so long they just made him a janitor one
time in middle school he was there
probably i remember him being like he
could piss his trick was he coming while
you were peeing at the urinal he'd piss
over you enter the urinal
and uh and finally he was in fifth grade
for so long they just made him a janitor
i mean he's probably still if that
school's still open he's probably still
there can you imagine only being in
fifth grade they pull you so listen
you've been talking here the staff has
been talking
it's not gonna work out for you but
lucky for you we have an opening in the
janitorial services department
what does that mean listen we'll give
you a dollar fairy dollar we'll match it
so you can join the army when you're 30.
i just love that that probably means he
was at least 16 or something so that was
what like seven times going through the
fifth grade i'll tell you something when
i was beautiful you were stupid really
handsome too listen when i was a kid if
you were stupid they pulled you aside
when you were 16. yeah the teachers at
school pull yourself a listen oh my god
you're wasting your time here
when you get to high school just sign
out you get a job as a mechanic
i swear to god teachers were honest in
the 70s well that's a better way now
that they want everybody to push forward
you know i remember the first wigger
went to our school i told you guys that
before the first wiggitus kid brian st
pierre went to our school
and he uh they'd never seen it before
you know and they thought he was
mentally handicapped they put him in
they made him eat the third lunch you
know the third lunch a special lunch
where those kids are in there you know
they make some of their own food and
then they eat it
you know to make them have a talent and
uh
and he was in there do this wiggle so
you'd have like you know you have like
kids who really had mental illnesses and
you know everything all the ds and
everything and then you'd have [ __ ]
brian st pierre wearing a charlotte
hornet's pullover dribbling an invisible
basketball all day bro just posting up
middle kids
in the lunch line bro they'd never seen
it they thought he was mentally
handicapped just because he wanted to
you know play with the brothers
just different times they had him cook
lunch every day still like he didn't say
anything once a week they'd have them
make some of their own recipes for lunch
you know it's kind of was cool i mean we
had a good we had a good group of
handicapped kids at our school i
remember i'm [ __ ] up dawg those stars
hit me hard tonight that's what happens
you know why they hit me hard because i
trained last week i didn't eat stars
last week lee sprayed out of his face i
didn't even get a boy this week at all i
sprayed it but i'm still i'm sorry
you're still here you kept eating stars
and [ __ ] [ __ ] around i had
transmissions
no you didn't you threw a chocolate away
oh jesus so this is why i have to do
everything on periscope
least fearless man i'll see how you do
it lee i really don't he's really not a
good choice anymore he does like a
little bit he goes like this in front of
the camera because i'm gonna eat some
chocolate he takes a bit right there
he's chews and then this this 80
milligrams whatever he throws this away
he tells people he ate it and tonight he
ate the whole thing and it was coming
through his [ __ ] fingers you should
have seen him he was gilling out huh you
know when you were telling your story
bro the thing that
uh i was thinking about the most was it
the 200 of those stories that i had that
i wish i had the time
i wish i had the [ __ ] time to
and i got 10 that roll around in my head
sometimes and one of them pop up
in the middle of the night before i'm
about to fall asleep and my whole body
shatters bro
those are those type of stories
especially when it comes to drugs yeah
especially when it comes to [ __ ]
drugs
and you the next morning you wake up and
you're like that's [ __ ] up i gotta get
my life together i gotta call somebody
and [ __ ]
but
you know ten days later it happens again
and
you know and sometimes it's it's sex so
sometimes it's it's crazy sex you go to
a girl's house my husband her sister and
her stepfather in the room yeah and
everybody's banging and you're like what
the [ __ ] am i a part of you know i just
want to watch the [ __ ] nickname
is that a real scenario lee you would be
[ __ ] surprised what you bump out into
when you're out there yeah
especially when i started to do comedy
you'd be surprised
what i'd bump into and i had you one
night talking my body was shaking yeah
my body was shaking telling the legion
just triple tours just
boulder just you know
i thought life was a certain way when i
lived in new jersey oh yeah i remember
boy was i [ __ ] wrong i remember
trying to [ __ ] this girl on roller
skates one time you ever tried to do
that dude no at halloween unbelievable
bro but that was drug induced
i remember never been arrested
uh dude i got arrested in mississippi
one time we're all high at some house
and they brought a kid the cops show up
and they brought a kid from downstairs
right and they said this kid is here
everybody's going in for contributing
delinquency of a minor
um
and then you could but once you got
outside kids were paying and getting out
of the thing they put us in the lead
like the slave shackles you know the
things they put between two legs you
know and then hook you to the person in
front of you
uh
so it was the dumbest thing ever bro it
must have taken us 40 minutes to get
downstairs in these [ __ ] leg shackles
with these two stupid cops but they
brought this kid down and then later
there was a rumor that they were this
was this kid this was a stage kid they
would hi they would pay in somebody's
kid to [ __ ]
they would sneak him in the back and put
him in people's houses and come down in
pajamas and then making money because
they're busting everybody in the house
because now they got a charge on
everybody contributing
um
what else did i go in before
nothing nothing real serious man no god
bless you man listen
but that was the thing i just wanted to
get i didn't i just yeah part of me was
86 you got a [ __ ] career
you're on the upswing right now
you know what you [ __ ] around you got
your dick sucked
i'm not telling you to uh go get married
but
it's time to start watching your back
because this is when you're a good
looking guy
shows are getting developed and written
you could be the number two dude
pick up the check five years no drama
you know you already did it yeah i've
had so much fun bro you know once you
get everything out of the way this place
becomes a complete different animal yeah
you know and listen lindsay lohan
survived it
uh the [ __ ] hilton kid survived it
some people don't yeah some people don't
man i told you when i walked in here
i'm not
i'm i'm happy about the podcast i'm
happy i get to see lee
and we get high and we talk [ __ ] and
he makes a living and i make a living
and we sell tickets and you know guys
like you come on here and people get to
hear you
[Music]
i like doing stand up i don't think i
could do this [ __ ] if i was doing blow
yeah there's no [ __ ] way
this this podcast would have been done
it would have fell apart lee would have
been to lee wouldn't even have been
talking to me no more at this point
lee would have gone he left me there
four [ __ ] days in a row you know
who's going to come out of the house
yeah yeah that was the thing i was just
like i just don't i need to take a if
this is where i'm kind of ending up once
in a while even once in a while i just
want to get it so nothing happened after
the cab ride after that that shook you
enough oh well with seeing daryl
strawberry is what shook me the next day
because he was 13 years sober and he was
like uh i mean this dude was eloquent he
had his life put together he's a
multi-millionaire now and then he was
pushing the the documentary 30 30 the
new one with doc gooden but doc goodman
wouldn't shut up good and we couldn't
show up because he's all [ __ ] up yeah
he's all [ __ ] up and i know my life is
in their lives but it made me think
okay you just gotta monitor what's going
on because i just yeah i don't like to i
didn't like to party i just like to put
myself in a crazy situation [ __ ] yeah me
too you know i was that's what i was
thinking about the whole time you're
saying that i go yeah i don't miss the
drugs i miss the six o'clock on a diner
or
waking up and some girl gives you an
audi to drive home
you're like what the [ __ ] just happened
last night yeah dude i was in louisville
one time i came out of a show they had a
big group in a limousine they invited me
to go to after party with them right i
was like i'm only coming if my boy can
come in like who's your boy and i'm like
le cedric they had a brother nearby
right wearing this louis vuitton jacket
dude
probably about 60 homeless right
and they're like that's your boy and i
didn't even talk to this dude right i
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come so i [ __ ] walk over
him looking right in the eyes and i was
like what's up man i'm theo he's like
and uh i was like all right dude i told
these people you're my friend you ever
been in a limousine he's like nah i was
like all right come get him with us just
act like you're my friend right we're
going to a party he's like all right man
so we go in the limo bro we're in there
hot chicks dudes people [ __ ] little
cedric kept saying we're friends that's
what he kept saying out loud
not the best actor bruh
what did we get to this house party it's
a nice cool [ __ ] party bro
i'm downstairs i'm in the kitchen
somebody's making us a drink i'm talking
to somebody
[ __ ] is six minutes later right here if
i get somebody scream i hear a window
break right
somebody comes running down they said
some dude just stole like four purses
out of the coat room upstairs and
[ __ ] jumped out a window
that would have been me doug
and that was [ __ ] less cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something i remember she got pissed she
was a tough girl she was like one of
those uh what are those people that
slide the thing on the ice she said
curlers
she was a curler
but i was
in my head i was like this is the best
[ __ ] night ever
no that's
so just [ __ ] like that where i just love
to put
life just in precarious situations man
did you black out ever you're never
going to get into another house party
ever oh i blacked out one time here in
hollywood and that scared me i woke up
in my own bed had no claw got there i'd
wet the bed i mean i wet the bed i was
about 30 anyway
did you two not filter until i was like
a teenager oh that's nothing bro
and uh
and and that was a pretty crazy night
one second you went the bets you were
13.
probably i don't know be probably around
there i would guess yeah i gotta watch
you like dogs damn those people always
awesomeness
it might have been a little bit like
maybe not 13 but close maybe 10
at least
well 10 ain't far from 13 if you're
talking at least
no but yeah i know i had a huge issue
with it it was terrible dude i used to i
used to have those buzzer underwear bro
they put these underwear on you when the
urine would hit them a buzzer would go
off oh my god
i'm not joking look him up online this
ain't no joke bro so i went to my
grandparents my mother didn't tell them
that i had these right i'm really hoping
these are a real thing you're not just
like a torture device your parents put
on not at all they made by themselves
this doctor gave them to us dude this
dude was above google his dude was a
bona fide doctor so we went there i got
the electric pants on dude you know
wait wait would you like google i'm
getting my rest probably uh you know
buzzer underwear for urinators
google buzzer underwear for urinators um
and uh so then
but they didn't tell my grandfather
right
so he [ __ ] had a small house bro a
little bitty house
so my [ __ ] crotch is just but like he
he wakes up middle of the night dude
you're on fire
i'm not on fire but i'm buzzing hard bro
cause i had apple juice man and i pissed
big on apple juice dude i [ __ ] spray
out on the aj
so i'm in there just buzzing dude i
didn't know gosh and he came in he still
got him
yeah give me a penalty
that's what i want give me a pen he
didn't know what was going on oh my god
that's what he comes in he's scared
how loud is this in a little bitty house
you could you could hear from down i
just want to wake my wife up in the
middle of that like twice a week
i would just do two drops and you and it
goes off
and uh
and so my grandfather's in there right
and he's all scared and [ __ ] and uh oh
this would have been terrible when i was
a kid and he's pushing me with a
broomstick dude he thought i was dead
dude he didn't know what had happened
and we thought was possessed or dead
he's pushing me with a broomstick to
wake me up and he was worried because he
had one of those heart makers
and he was worried he would get
electrocuted he thought something was
happening he thought the house had
short-circuited it or the phone company
had [ __ ] up that's what he thought the
phone company
so he thinks i'm [ __ ] just laying
there buzzing like there's a [ __ ]
miscreant
but he died man my grandfather
oh
he died i love
people i love laughing
i love laughing and [ __ ] like this
that's you can't write this i forgot
about that
i did it man
this has been the batman i appreciate
you had me on because i've been i was
sick the past two days man what was
wrong with you
oh man i had adult diarrhea bro to be
honest
it happens those [ __ ] flights
you're eating [ __ ] katrina leftover
stuff oh yeah i still got some guys got
in stock oh they're serving [ __ ]
crippled pig [ __ ] down there bro and i
was eating about a handful
[ __ ] around down there jack
oh my god i'm high on those stars
because like i said
i ate [ __ ] transmission fluid and a
couple of these moon things
then i had killed the cookies was then i
ate the transmission fluid and the moon
thing
and i was home all night with my oh my
god i [ __ ] killed those cookies i
want some cookies man dude i ate half of
a pot cookie one time i never had one
there's a couple years ago i invited
this casting director right out to a
comedy show
so she comes but the comedy show was the
next night i had the knights wrong
so i felt bad and she was cute and i was
like well at least i'll get her dinner
because she came all this way i didn't
want to be like a you know just like you
said like a mook you know so by this
lady dinner we're sitting there eating
dinner she gave me a pot cookie
and i got high man i never had one and i
didn't know how we knew each other
and it was like a nice restaurant and i
started thinking that this was like my
girlfriend you know i was like [ __ ] dude
i'm the war
and uh i try to make a move on about a
cab stand dude and she's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing you know
and uh she wasn't my girlfriend man
and uh
anyway
that was it
that was it dude but uh yeah yeah subs
dangerously
i think it's what i'm getting at here
i thought it was a buzzer like a
vibrating no it's like a like a it makes
a little sound
i still can't get over you got the car
drove an hour and a half
to go to an apartment
yeah airbnb is not for anyone
when you told me that way yeah
i was like i can't
this is a horror show this is so what
happened what are you mad at being
before yeah you should host a romantic
getaway
[ __ ] i'm not mad at airbnb it's just
it's a weird
it was just weird it was just this
person's apartment
and like her stuff was there
it was just her bed like i was like we
should bring sheets
i was just it was just not you brought
your own sheets i wanted to but we
didn't
she's like no this is what they do they
make money doing this this is all they
have at the
it's an interest i don't know but it's
an industry yeah i don't
i don't like i like hotels so from now i
just said from now on we'll do hotels
yeah man splurge man throw the extra
nine dollars out there and get a [ __ ]
he's young he knows all this no i've
been to hotels he knows how to flamingo
he'll get that yeah he'll get 90 percent
off [ __ ] hotels
oh you should be at him dean del rey
they know how to get a hotel room i
don't know
people try to be like i don't know it's
it's cool it's like you get to be as
part of the community it was right on
the beach which was nice but oh wow i
didn't know that but like it was cool
but i'd still rather be in a hotel on
the freeway
it's just i don't know like even though
i know more people probably are on those
sheets to be honest
and the sheets made you nervous
yeah i do
you've cooked everything
ever no i need to i didn't cook i didn't
cook with none other silverware but
ever since i've been with him i just get
unlocked i've never had i never had skin
issues and now i get styes
if i look at a hot tub
trust me
his ear is swollen
that's why i sleep on my stomach i was
trying to sleep on your stomach i do
like a [ __ ] dead animal
like an armadillo yeah or on my side i'm
or mostly either my stomach or my size
do your arms touch the ground yeah how
do you even do that
you have no idea though guys who sleeps
on your stomach face down no i said yeah
oh face to the side i have pillows yeah
oh face to the side jesus christ i
thought you slept face down maybe i have
like
dude you're a [ __ ] unreal league i
figured what we were talking about they
should have dolls they should have to
leave cyan dolls bro
they're indestructible dude
okay it was just
airbnb it was not i would it's a hotel
it just was just
i get it in like places where you want
to rent a cabin or something was it a
spare bedroom or what was it we had a
full apartment we had a full apartment
it was her personal bedroom though
yes okay see that's disgusting yeah all
that people bang in my bed and come on
my headboard and [ __ ] people
we disrespected that let me tell you
something you just come on the headboard
and rub it in like [ __ ]
lemon what's that joey what's that [ __ ]
you polished wood with us
they come back they gotta sleep with
that old dna of diaz lurking over your
head and [ __ ] yeah old english that's a
liquor and it's a malt lick that's why
we left that which i just i didn't it
was gonna rain there was gonna be
fireworks so we were gonna stay if there
was gonna be fireworks but then it was
raining and it was just like this
person's it was like her college
apartment kind of
it was like everything that was like
someone else went to ikea
and we stayed out of the dorm at [ __ ]
pretty much i'll stay long beach it was
not good it was not great but my my
my my girlfriend is
young and but she means she no she the
activities were great and she just isn't
making a lot of money yet so did she
have a good time yeah oh yeah we had
another time the activity isn't great
dude
dude she had a good time lee
that's what counts oh yeah of course and
we had a great time we have a great time
together just
that's love i'm i'm the the old uh weird
one who just wants to be in hotels but
um
now do you try to act not older on your
girlfriend if she's younger that's one
thing i've noticed i'm not that much i'm
like two years older oh that's not bad
that's not weird um that's not bad but
people should go to museum stoned more
it's fun it's like that have you been to
the queen mary no i've been to the other
place the museum down there the [ __ ]
zoolandia the aquarium water yeah it's
cooling down there yeah the aquarium was
fun too yeah
it's a nice tight it's beautiful down
there it really is day we did long beach
yeah i'm saying it's just not a vacation
resort and we had the best mexican food
i've had
in calgary that's the first thing i said
to you in that afternoon
i go make sure you get the mexican food
but don't get a [ __ ] chain my boy
simon rex is uh we're going down there
with him a couple do you know him simon
rex dirt nasty no no no oh you got to
meet him he's great bro so funny
no it's uh
it's great to [ __ ] get sober man
yeah it's cleared my head up a little
bit so but listen man i don't give a
[ __ ] when anybody tells you
and the quicker you catch yourself
the better off it is you know yeah and
it might take you a year to get sober
but
it's so good when you do you feel better
five more what's the difference right
now that you feel
yeah i mean i feel like
no reefer no sleeping pills no no no
nothing just straight up water maybe
somehow i'll hit up a cialis 5 milligram
you know if i'm trying to party a little
you know if i'm trying to treat a lady
to an evening or something but uh
you know i'll drop nine dollars on that
i got a dude that'll you know
when does that start happening what
the seattle's five milligrams oh i throw
that just because look dude you know
what i'm saying like
you know i can be michael jordan but if
i could have scottie pippen next to me
bro i'll do it you know like there's no
point not having him in the ring with
you you know
you know you don't show you you know you
got to bring a you got to bring a knife
to a bun fight you know what i'm saying
yeah it's so petrified to eat one of
those things oh you gotta throw dude
i'll tell you i'll put one of those in
my butt dude they go quick to you cocked
in dude what is this [ __ ]
in the last week we've had somebody who
put what did she put in her [ __ ]
oh yeah boof and these kids are boofing
where they blow cocaine in each other's
butts
i read about that that's a colorada
thing what do they do
they put cocaine in the end of a straw
and then they put the other they put the
other end into somebody's butt and then
they blow it in there
i did that 25 [ __ ] years ago i
invented that one
with a dollar bill you boof with a
dollar bill
you get the hepatitis c attached to the
dollar bill and [ __ ]
if i don't have hepatitis c i ain't got
nothing
man bro from all those [ __ ] dollar
bills and snorting that [ __ ]
hysterical oh my god what the [ __ ] so
yeah i hit a sabbatical man but i hit a
sabbatical so that's where i'm at you
know but it's chill i just feel what i
feel i feel
because i just got a lot on my plate
right now and at least each time i can
show up for it you know it's like every
day i know i can do what's going what's
required of me you know because my mind
already tries to beat me up a lot my
mind you know first thing out of the
game my mind is like you [ __ ] you know
you [ __ ] sometimes my mind calls me a
[ __ ] even you know like jesus christ i
guess my own brain using the n word
you know and it's just like that stuff's
just channelizing you know sometimes so
so at least i know each day when i'm
sober it's like if i haven't been
drinking a party and then i'm able to
get up and like
battle my own demons and go at the day
head on you know
and i still i got enough war stories and
now i'm able to think out my war stories
a little bit better because sometimes i
was too busy making news stories to even
think about the old ones so now i'm able
to look through the old and be like oh
this could be a good story and i can
share those stories so i feel like my
stand-up has gotten better
you know i put it together a new hour in
the past year
you really shoot another special i'm
ready man you feel good about it oh i
feel good dude where would you shoot
this time this time i would do chicago
or i would do here in l.a i think
because i got enough friends that
understand me
you know and it might be delusional
otherwise i would do dallas
dallas bro i love those people they're
[ __ ] everything dude you work them
down the improv
yeah i worked the improv but i worked
the one out in uh ireland yeah addison
addison yeah i worked at addison i was
one of my favorite clubs it is a great
club isn't it
one of my favorite but the hotel used to
be
50 yards away now they switched that
there
the one i stayed at was really close you
could walk a walk how many minutes
literally not even joking
two and a half minutes
maybe less then they put you back at the
hotel they said they took you out of so
i was like nah oh they did take you out
for a little while because first time i
went they had me stay at some other
place down the street and they had to
drive down there or some [ __ ] [ __ ] that
yeah i don't do that
i don't do that [ __ ] man but yeah man i
had some other crazy i mean i remember
one night body slamming a bunch of
hookers dressed up like a [ __ ]
genghis khan doing get korean hookers
and
one of the last times i saw you you had
gone out one night you went to the
apartment
and you were gacked up and you called
the chick and they sent you the wrong
chick
oh yeah some lady had a uh
a uh
was it a
oh some lady with a mole that a big mole
and i set up with my buddies a
dermatologist
i don't even know how to answer that
yeah but
hookers and stuff were never really my
deal i mean my deal was just i would
just want to party and create stories
you know
like i never got into really
that i mean that guy brought the hooker
under the taxi you know that's luigi's
deal that's his life it was nice of him
because i think he was trying to be a
friend of me but
you know i didn't want i didn't need
that you know i was just looking to
party
truly when you live a certain lifestyle
you come to a point one night when you
go you know what i can't do this no more
because eventually
something bad is gonna happen luigi
could have stabbed me yeah the hooker
could have slit in my throat while i was
putting my neck back
to put coke in my nose a [ __ ]
thousand things
could go wrong
you know from experienced man now if i
could do it again
i always minded my business listen i
went into those neighborhoods late at
night
i think about it my [ __ ] skin like
just wants to shake like a spirit touch
me yeah it's the weirdest thing like i
remember
being at a bar in like fort lee new
jersey
and knowing that
the places and i closed at three we got
to make it over that three in the
morning but when you get to that place
the place is closed so now you gotta get
to the bronx are you [ __ ] kidding me
now you gotta cross a bridge on another
bridge we're coking your [ __ ] car
don't they're confiscating that car and
you're doing seven and a half years
somewhere yeah and you're still doing it
yeah and you're still going to that bad
neighborhood and that's all you need
is for a cop to see a hooker walk
towards your car
and her talking to you you're getting
pulled over yeah it's that easy they see
a woman
18 inches from your car you're getting
[ __ ] pulled though unless you miss
victoria dude who just dropped her ass
into your passenger seat dude that lady
would hang out the side of your car
i mean that was i mean that's basically
the uh what's that food place where you
go when they run out to your car and set
the thing on the tray on the side
sonic sonic but i was basically the
sonic oh hookers that lady
well tony better than a monday the first
monday
of the new year look at you and [ __ ]
amen man
good to be here man
good to have you
happy new year ah happy new year
victoria i wonder what she's up to now
who's victoria the hooker
that lady would drop her ass in your car
for
16 18 bucks probably
i stopped by my old neighborhood the
other day actually
tell you about that next time
how you feeling
how you feeling
i'm feeling uh so the star stayed in you
the chocolates came out yeah someone
what's up hey i also ate the first half
of the chocolate bar
so it was like
something
some parts of something stayed animated
whatever's in there is working
unreal oh my god
it's on [ __ ] periscope
that's the [ __ ] craziest thing
you got the whole thing i pretty you
know you always do great i
i i thought to yourself oh he bought
four bars he trained last week like a
soldier
but as it was happening i go i should
have known
i shouldn't know i had that feeling like
ronda rousey when she was standing next
to the
referee i should have known this was a
hoax listen i mean i mean no disrespect
i know a lot of great people who make a
lot of great edibles
chocolate doesn't really ever sit well
in my stomach it's weird wow i'm a
chubby dude who just chocolate is not
yeah not in there for me
you ain't no chocolate guy i'm gonna
remember that no sir
how many weeks a month are you traveling
now probably 20 weeks
i do like 20 weeks on the road and i
spend time with my family so i do three
weeks at home during the year
um
and then i i'm doing enough work in town
where it's good to be home you know
like i can make
you know i can make decent money just
even staying in the city
you go out every night during the week
five nights a week i say i get up damn
actually i'll probably get up six dude
honestly i try to take one off though
just to make sure that i'm able to
know what i'm doing when i get to the
club you know
if i'm in training i want to be out six
nights a week and get six sets
if i'm [ __ ] around i like to do four
yeah i'll go out one night and bang two
just so i'm out three nights and i could
stay friday night my family leave it
open you know what i'm saying oh you
mean on the road yeah i have to go out
twice a month man yeah twice a month
that's what i like to do twice a month
is that the most i could do
six nights let's do this [ __ ] do this
[ __ ]
do this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] lee sciatica look
at you
with a new shirt on what'd you do with
the old shirt
it's not bad it's an odds in the trunk
of my car i just couldn't i just didn't
want to wear a stinky shirt
but oh my god that was [ __ ]
and you just eat them like they're
nothing which is the weirdest part to me
there's no beautiful there's no [ __ ]
state of mind like there's no state of
mind but things have taste
it's chocolate
it's chocolate i don't taste nothing i
was thinking about it the other day
mushrooms have [ __ ] on them and he just
told me not all of them oh yeah they do
only the ones i gave you i cleaned off
it you don't clean nothing off yes
personally cleaned the [ __ ] mushrooms
off for you why would i lie before you
came in
i was telling lee that you know what man
i really like the holidays
but those five days afterwards just
really rough on me man yeah i just want
new years to [ __ ] come and go i had a
nice time new year's i'm happy joe had
me open for him
done at the orpheum tony hinchcliffe
nice [ __ ] people
yeah we did the show and got the [ __ ]
out of there nobody hung out nothing
but uh you know i was home by a quarter
to 12. that's beautiful bam nobody got
their feelings hurt my wife was out you
know
but that's it i i'm not doing it no more
i've done enough you know what i'm
saying yeah 25 years i've done probably
[ __ ] 20 years of uh
new year's that's it man i've bombed
hard on [ __ ] new years news is hard
new year's is hard i bombed
[ __ ] hard one of the hardest bombs in
my life
was miami improv where i was [ __ ]
kicking ass as a feature act yeah new
year's
like
99. oh did i eat a bag of [ __ ] in front
of angel salazar haha really oh boy i
saw him at a diner in new york not long
ago how bad does he look dude i swear to
god joy i'm walking with sarah tiana you
know her yeah
and there's a guy sitting in the diner
by himself it's 2 30 in the morning
we've been in the at the comedy clubs
and stuff we're gonna eat
and i'd never met angel in my life i'd
only heard stories about him right and
i'd seen a couple pictures
and i was like i think that's angel
salazar he's drinking a glass of wine in
a shitty diner
we go in dude and it was him
and we sat there and talked to him for a
while he tried to [ __ ] sarah a little
bit
which i respected yeah and then uh how
are you
what's your name yeah you want to go
into the low with me
it was cool to see him man because i
only heard stories he works in
percentages he's a
he's an interesting [ __ ] fellow you
know what man
he gave me a lot of encouragement early
on you know i can't lie he's a good dude
in that way
when i got to meet him
it was i i appreciated what he had done
i i just that was a little too fast for
me he was rocking and rolling jack yeah
he part he used to party hard that's
what i mean he goes hard and i was going
hard at the time i was going wow
this guy goes [ __ ]
hard like el paso we get to el paso it
was tuesday through saturday night
let me tell you something
as soon as i got down there there was
somebody waiting for me with a chunk
that just got over a border in
somebody's shoe
that first night will be smelled like a
size 10. i get [ __ ] lit up
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] tremendous you
know and from there on every night there
was somebody at the club with something
that's el paso bro
when he would come to town the phone at
the condo would start ringing the night
before wow
people guys angel there yet
people wanted to take them out and
that scarface thing people will be when
he's 80 and a funeral in a in an old
man's home every day somebody will be
taking them out taking pictures of them
check it out yeah buying them lunch
bringing them clothes it's amazing
people fell in love with that character
hard it just goes to show you he still
sells tickets
he's not
selling out right but he still sells
tickets he's not
[ __ ] michael jackson right but he
still sells 100 tickets a show doesn't
matter he takes pictures
people go there look at them it's 30
[ __ ] years later that was 30 goddamn
years ago right that's amazing 83 well
yeah 83 90 boom boom yeah that's amazing
he was born in 94 right 88 88 94 who
gives a frenchman [ __ ] you insanely yeah
[ __ ] lee brah
unbelievable i'm just happy to see you
alive every time i come back in here man
and always boost my spirits to know
you're still going you know we ain't
going nowhere i know she's gonna know
indestructible we're gonna take leave
her right now we'll talk on this [ __ ]
kick him out the car make him walk home
and stuff
me the hooker and his name is uh
luigi
in a car we need to scan lee a little
bit at night at least never really had
fun yeah we need to get you out in one
of the neighborhoods one night dude get
you in a little clan outfit
sure
take him out
it's gonna go great right now
my god i'm joking bro you i don't know
if you you i don't think you'd make a
good cleanse mentally no i wouldn't
yeah i don't think he would
he's jewish
yeah you could claim you could cross
over though because you have to be
christian first to be a classmate you
probably do
i think it's like kind of you just can't
be you can't be jewish
it'll be like hey what are you talking
about what do you want to do this year
man there's a comic this year man i want
to get it this i want to get this other
special i got my new album that's going
to come out soon we just just uh
just locked it actually about three days
ago
called 30 pound bag of hamster bones
uh
and so i'm excited about that
um
and what else man we got a couple of
great shows that we're pitching so i'm
excited about that i wouldn't mind
meeting a girl maybe falling in love you
know or at least being an honorable
boyfriend you know i don't know if i've
ever been that in my life dude you know
i was out there
you know licking [ __ ] after dark you
know out there in the streets and just
you know just tasting the flavors of the
universe you know now that you quit
drinking it's a different game out there
huh
it's not that easy to lure them back oh
no girls want you more now
do they oh i think in a heartbeat yeah
i've had more offers these days for like
i've just had more office i think just
because i'm because you look like you do
wait like i don't like that because i'm
clear ahead if i go sober it's not like
people are gonna be like oh lee i want
to suck your dick
no
they might late i don't think so you
know bro they might look i didn't think
i you know
i've never thought i was uh
very handsomely if that makes you feel
any better you're stunning sir well it's
nice you to say
but yeah i think so those are some of my
work dreams you know outside of that i
want to be a better brother um i want to
be a i want to have a little bit more
relationship with with a god you know a
higher power
um
yeah those are things that i want to do
man and i want to help other people
somehow i just want to do something even
if it's little you know answer the phone
when somebody calls if i know they need
help not that i would even if it's some
muppet you know that i normally wouldn't
[ __ ] answer you know you're 36 this
is about the time that you got to sit
there and go jesus christ
what's next now i did this i did this i
did this i did this
yeah what the [ __ ] does it go where does
it end up do i join the beatles yeah you
know this is this is a
i moved here you know like at 30
something
and it was rough
i don't know for sure and i'm like if i
fail at this
i don't have a lot of options
i could sell over the phone i could sell
cars and [ __ ]
i don't think i could sell things over
the phone for 20 [ __ ] years so i had
so i got to make this comedy [ __ ] work
one way or another like that's how i
know
this was it man
wow that's brave bro
that's brave because i had done
everything else
yeah
come on who the [ __ ] are you kidding not
every opportunity in the world to learn
how to be a brick mason
a roofer
oh yeah i could have been a thousand
things an electrician
electrician i could have been a [ __ ]
those people would like pipe for the
[ __ ] pipes
yeah the irritation oh the irrigation
irrigation pipes some guy [ __ ] when i
was 19 said listen man
work the summer if you like it invest a
little bit
if you like it you [ __ ] stay around
we raise your salary if you like it you
buy in he goes i'm partners with these
two guys we make a little [ __ ] we cut it
up every month
it's not a lot but at least you make
some money you know
it wasn't a bad deal though i got great
i had great opportunities when i was a
young man yeah
[ __ ] great opportunities and i would
they would come to me and listen man
just stick around you're a sharp guy
stick around
stick around i want to run this place
tomorrow yeah you can't be like that
you can't and because of stupid [ __ ] i
lost great jobs you know but i'm happy i
did
because i wouldn't be where i am
i wouldn't found
what i really wanted to do you know what
i'm saying oh 100 it's kind of awkward
why you're going through it i know right
a lot of people right now they're
listening to this are going through that
they're going through stuff transition
from one situation to another yeah it
seems like you just have to keep [ __ ]
pushing
yeah because your life or your higher
power has a plan for you bro even if you
and i i'm not trying to sound like some
christian weirdo or anything like that
i'm just saying that
life has a plan for you and you just
gotta [ __ ] you know if you out there
getting you getting your ass eaten
through a car window or whatever you're
doing just know that that's not that
doesn't define you and that's just a
little speed bump you know that's just a
little
that's a little ingredient in your
recipe man because dude i used to bury a
guy's [ __ ] in my neighborhood for free
when i was growing up you know he died
you know i i lived such a [ __ ]
the other part of this holiday i didn't
like today was i had a great christmas
eve
christmas eve was [ __ ] phenomenal the
family and we had a great christmas too
that was all cool
it was like uh
tuesday and wednesday got real like what
the [ __ ] do you do all day damn you hey
dude you had a tough you had a tough
time after that after that christmas my
back's what my wife's back was hurt oh i
was at the park with the baby to be
honest you're riding a little bike with
her and stuff like that you know
she got a bike request i was a [ __ ]
blast
but
you know after that i was like what do
you do you wait till 10 45 to go to the
store yeah you're like [ __ ] dying i
want [ __ ] to happen you're like come on
baby let's shoot something yeah life
slows down life slows down man
for me
[ __ ]
i ain't getting no younger dog
yeah
you don't need it like you don't feel
like you need like a
three four days to do nothing
he probably do
see that's what i'm wondering too how do
you not feel like that man
that's how i would feel a lot that's how
i feel sometimes i'm happy to have that
down time i had down time
in my world that was down time yeah
those couple days over christmas that's
down time but you had too much of it
you're recharging blah blah blah blah in
the back of my mind i want to be writing
i couldn't really write everybody was
around me
you know it was kind of distracting over
the house it was just yeah
it's a bit much sometimes bro i did
write the [ __ ] book though
i did write the book every day whether
it was a sentence a paragraph
a new chapter i cut something in i did
do that
which was interesting that's good
but the problem is when you go on the
road i lose that
because the computer i have on the road
just sucks [ __ ] dick well
it's a surface and my wife is gonna get
me another one i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened i gotta ask her what the
[ __ ] happened yeah i really you know
what i only focus on that stuff when i'm
home
and i only focus in when it's early in
the morning yeah i really like to lock
myself in like take two hits of the pipe
and i
watch that [ __ ] you know daddy work yeah
it's good man that's when your brain is
nice you get to watch the ronda rousey
fight and loose
now honestly bro i don't like watching
women fight bro like i like i watched a
lot of women's street fight when i was
growing up there's a lot of uh
yeah
these chicks were always [ __ ]
fighting around now so some of it i
don't like i do respect it i think these
women are tough and talented you know
unbelievable did you watch it lately yes
sir what did you think
i thought well personally and i've said
this before that i thought
just
unsure that like they won the i was like
why are they making rhonda the favorite
she's been gone for a year and this
other girl has been crazy good
for a while
and
my dad was saying today that usually she
usually attacks and just gets people
down and in 12 seconds they're done and
she didn't seem like she had the same
urgency this time that's what he said he
he's a very amateur fan
and to me
i i don't even know about that it just
seemed like
i don't know if she has to be there for
a contract or
it like it didn't even it didn't even
look like uh
a fight was put up to me i thought it
was very sad
yeah i watched it i watched the replay
like i said yesterday i said you know
right before it started i went to the
bathroom
as i was pissing i said you know what
rob is going to win this fight let her
win
let her
retire
prevent her frustrations on the media
and how she felt and how she was treated
tell a few people to go [ __ ] themselves
and you never see ronda rousey again
unless she's a spokesman for fox sports
or something yeah
they'll get you know what nunez will
fight somebody for the interim belt and
she'll get the championship back
nobody's feelings get hurt here
this could be this couldn't end a better
way
i come back i sit down i put my feet up
and they're off
and i see what happened
a part of me was so [ __ ] sad
a part of me was so [ __ ] sad because
a part of me thought that she'd never
recover from that
if it took her that long
say what you want about conor mcgregor
he got choked up
and a week later he was out there
talking [ __ ]
that was the difference between
ronda and can i tell you i think the
difference is because that was the big
difference okay
you can't sit in your house we all lose
i understand you worked hard i work hard
you work hard
lee works hard we all [ __ ] work hard
bro
to to to to do anything in this business
yeah to make a dent in this business you
have to work hard to excel in your field
whatever field that you do
you have to put that extra [ __ ] hour
in that nobody knows about you know what
i'm saying yeah you get to work like ah
but you want that [ __ ] i.t job or
whatever job you want you gotta put an
extra two three hours on a sunday you
know what i'm saying yeah that's what
life is all about even if you do it at
home you wake up two hours earlier we
all [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
what are we talking about
rousey rousey
but you know now she's saying you know
they made a statement and dawg nobody
was sadder than i was
it's not like i better or nothing i just
there was no reason to you know it was i
was very entertained with dominic cruz
and the other guy if i was gonna bet
anything that fight i was just gonna sit
back and watch
and while it was going down man i
thought about everything and i'm like
you know again i saw hitting pads with
the guy
i saw doing
nothing different yeah
i didn't see nobody different sparring
with a
i didn't see no kickboxer in there
spying whether yeah i just saw a hitting
pads
and it all came to me and i felt sad
and i feel sad that she lost
i can't imagine how bad she feels you
know yeah to lose two in a row and like
that unnatural this one here
i think a lot of people feel the way i
did she wasn't even in the game yeah it
seemed like at first when she got hit
it came to her that she was in the
[ __ ] octagon
that's what it seemed like to me
and she was all gone from there like
rogan said she threw a couple kicks
which is something out of her repertoire
and the move she does so greatly it was
greatly it was gracefully
that chick escaped from it and returned
the punch in there so
yeah i think maybe you could be riley
that was just a contractual thing you
know i i have no idea and
i i have no interaction with this guy
but why do you guys think
she sticks with a certain coach who
from whenever you hear
is maybe they love her no one likes no
well she's dating someone else who she
brought to that coach
i mean who knows i don't know
i don't know enough about it
bro you know man
sometimes loyalty is loyal to even
sometimes if it's blinded
if that's what it is with him and her
god bless her at least she's loyal with
someone you know what i'm saying oh hey
man they get a lot of the tapes are
being released from the fight and stuff
and
people have said something listen i'm
not an expert
in boxing or mma that talk about who's a
good coach who's not a good [ __ ]
coach i don't know anything about that
[ __ ]
all you know is the results
in the octagon or in the ring you know i
know freddie roach is good
because the filipino guy pacquiao has
been champion for 2000 years yeah i know
whoever tank trains floyd
mayweather
must be good because whoever trains him
i know the guys down winklejohn down
there down in new mexico they're good
they got jon jones they got bj penn they
got carlos conduit and all this goes on
and on and on
i know a lot of camps that are [ __ ]
great that don't mean the people
are going to be great there why ronda
after she got knocked out
by holly holm
why didn't she go starting new
i don't know
i mean she's been busy she's been she's
you know she's done a bunch of
advertising i mean who knows it's a good
question man i don't know enough about
it i got a [ __ ] pest so bad man so
guys go [ __ ] pee i gotta do some
shout outs real quick again this show is
presented from my favorite [ __ ]
in the world on it let me tell you
something about on it
i've been back on the shroom tech sport
again i gotta tell you people something
unbelievable again i tried to order the
hemp force protein today they didn't
have it so instead i got some alpha
brain
and i got one of the club bats
that's how i'm rolling for 2017
i suggest you do the same alpha brain
start with alpha brain because the money
back guarantee you're right and they
don't even want the product back you
think you're not sharp enough for 2017
it starts at alpha brain [ __ ] go to
hunter.com right now and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your first
order
on it.com again the code is church
c-h-u-r-c-h
i want to thank my main man
rory oliver for the badass bruce lee
book he brought me a [ __ ] d uh an old
g kundo book you know i love you jack
wil wilkin
cap
talking lair nick ferrara
ray majewski darren carter with his
[ __ ] push-ups uki spooky over the
holidays looking good
cj blake and rachel lay little over
there getting more married
down there [ __ ] houston
close that door for you uncle joey
though what's the matter
i was
raised i gotta slip jay
what time
i don't know what the [ __ ] i want to do
in 2017.
i just want to [ __ ] live lisa and i'm
gonna do a podcast a couple days a week
with my main man i want to be a better
dad i'm going to try to be a better
husband
and uh that's all you could [ __ ] be
you know what i'm saying i know i don't
want to travel anymore
as much as i'm doing
i got some cities that i got to go to
out of respect
you know so i gotta
pick my [ __ ] cities next year
and make them my decisions you know what
i'm saying yeah now i think it's
look man
i mean i just love watching you work man
so i'm happy to be watching your work
man i'm happy that
when we spoke on the phone today you
told me about your decision i'm kind of
listening i'm happy with anybody get
sober
i gotta tell you something even if you
you were my enemy you came to me you
know i got sober i've been sober eight
years i got the utmost respect for you
because i know where you've been
yeah listen man you want me to look in
the eye and tell you being sober is fun
sorry
i will never [ __ ] tell you
yeah man
i've had moments of clarity because
after i quit the coke
i went on like a 30 day or like a 40
something day no reefer thing where i
just ate pot cookies from the pharmacy
and i didn't smoke and i remember how
different everything felt and i wasn't
doing coke for a while
it
it's uh it's different when you have
control of your life totally yeah see
you could always turn down the bread off
the [ __ ]
cheeseburger yeah you could always go to
the [ __ ] gym
you could always you know not drink and
drive and [ __ ] like that but something i
always gave into was those [ __ ] drugs
man yeah
you know my life had total control
except those drugs but those drugs ruin
everything you're doing yeah just like
lee and i spoke about all the alcohol
all the heroin all the pills you think
you're making it happen i thought i was
making it happen and believe it or not
bro i was
booking big time movies
up but my comedy was eating [ __ ] yeah
you'd be thinking my comedy is [ __ ] now
you should have seen it 10 years ago
because there was no emotional
connection with cocaine and drinking
yeah there's no emotional connection you
just stuck there like a parrot
just [ __ ] talking stupidity so once
that whole booze
whenever i see a young comic on stage or
booze
it does something to me yeah because in
all my 25 years you know how many times
i brought booze up to the stage
maybe three times yeah i never thought
it'd look good
i always thought you'd give me like the
wrong impression i don't know why and i
have friends that do it i've never said
nothing it's not my [ __ ] business
what people do
in my mind i just never liked it i don't
know why
yeah i mean i think i could see that a
lot of comics like it because the bar
owners you saw more booze of the comics
drinking oh i didn't realize that
oh sure the comics drinking yeah makes
sense he's up there doing shots people
are going to start sending them shots
and who's not going to do a shot let me
do a shot with you afterwards let's do
another [ __ ] shot next thing you know
you're [ __ ] puking on stage and
you're bert naked on joe rogan's podcast
weighing in tonight he lost by two
pounds he lost by two pounds but they're
both under
uh
ob so i think the aria has to pay now
who already has to pay oh who won
uh well segura was 219 today
and bert was 221.
so but they're both they were they both
have to be under 227 so then
then if they're both under 227 then aria
has to pay wow what was the price
uh
no prize just
uh they had to they were both trying to
get under
obese and then there's no price what
does all you have to pay uh they're
going on a trip or to an event
nice it's a good deal
i gotta take a trip man i gotta i gotta
slip out of here joe where you going i
gotta go home i gotta we actually gotta
put an episode of my own podcast up so
we gotta go work with my editor
wow listen man i'm happy you dropped by
and opened up the [ __ ] year with us
my friend dude i wouldn't have any other
way back man i'm [ __ ] happy that you
can't come by so there's a fire out
there and [ __ ] [ __ ] burn it down bro
what a [ __ ] night tonight my friend
that's what's up
listen i couldn't wait to get out of the
house and do a [ __ ] podcast hey man i
did one last night with those guys
it went well i knew that would go well
with you whatever's burning down
[ __ ] [ __ ] close let it burn baby
trump baby let it burn dude
don't say that
sorry just let it burn
don't say that we're trapped in here
with no bicycles
i got no bicycle in here look at him we
got a chair to barricade ourselves with
no oxygen we'll be dead within two
[ __ ] minutes today bazooka this place
hilarious
all right my brother where you headed
this weekend
um this weekend on montana i'm in
virginia beach in a couple of weeks at
the funny bone the last weekend uh
january 20
um
six through the
january 24th through the 28th
are you writing your sobriety down are
you writing about your sobriety at all
i mean right now i'm just talking about
on stage i'm not talking oh yeah
i'm talking about
putting on a notebook about you what are
you feeling what the [ __ ] is different
why would i go back to drinking or
hanging out with characters like joe
diaz after 2 a.m
no right now i'm working a man i had
like i mean i didn't have a dad growing
up so i still have like a lot of like
emotional issues and stuff from growing
up so some of that stuff i got to deal
with so i mean i'm always doing my
comedy i mean my comedies i love my
comedy i'm happy to have it i feel
blessed to have this skill and ability
but at the same time like
i'm dealing with other personal stuff
first you know because that's what i got
to get right but at the same time my
comedies
is is is i feel like better than ever so
you know it's all simultaneous long as i
care about myself to keep working that
stuff then everything else will work
itself out
i gotta respect that man
you know i love you either whatever you
want to do
if you want to do bonus if you want to
do heroin i love you either way if you
want to stay clean i love you what can i
tell you i just want you to be happy and
get the best you know like we talked
about before the show listen
if you know anything about me bro i i
can't drive a bmw yeah i know what the
[ __ ] i am you know yeah
for me living here now and having a
great time like i said 20 years later
i seen so many people that had more
opportunity than me
vanish yeah spanish
sometimes i look them up on facebook i
see them
real estate now or something like that
but they vanish from this yeah you know
what this wasn't really a dream for me
this was more like uh
let's see what could happen
yeah in two years if i book an extra row
i'll be happy with that can you imagine
all i want to do is be an extra i never
thought mitzi was gonna make me a
regular [ __ ] like that yeah just to be
in this situation to wake up and to be
with lee i'm telling you man
i'm [ __ ] ecstatic yeah the other type
of comedy is too much [ __ ] pressure
if you look at it now from the
outside there's a level of comedy you
can live your life and do great
margaritas been doing it for years yeah
she's just been sliding through
everybody else is doing this and doing
that margaret cho still selling out
improvs on the weekend bro yeah
what the [ __ ] are you kidding she's been
doing this for 30 years
if i've been doing this for 25 she's
been doing this for 30 years
you just [ __ ] take it as three months
off and reinvent yourself rather special
do this do that you know and you're good
you're young man you got the world by
the ball so oh i've already lived out i
mean i've already all my dreams i feel
like i've already had almost in a lot of
ways so i feel like i'm [ __ ] just
playing around and over you know like
i've far exceeded my expectations how
many years you've been here so far i've
been doing comedy 13 years how many
years you've been in los angeles 13
12. then [ __ ] it theo ron you know what
write it out yeah you might as well go
to hollywood alone and buy a plot and
say listen i'll see you guys in 80
[ __ ] years all right bury me
it's done right here bury me face down i
want that lee syed treatment you know
you don't want to be over in louisiana
you want to be buried here oh i want to
get buried over there in mississippi i
already found a graveyard i liked it did
you really yeah they got a brother that
cuts it dude a brother cuts the grass
and wears a full suit when he cuts it
every sunday no matter how hot he is i
feel like he probably won't be there
when he when he got there no this man
will be cutting grass forever bro
and he wears a suit where's his face on
the top of the scene he cuts it and you
got little hills out there and a man
cuts it in a suit how do you get home
you take two flights
i sometimes i take one in new orleans
and then drive north
sometimes i take two in the baton rouge
that's where my family's at now in baton
rouge
but
uh yeah man i had a great holidays man
and it started off great dude did a show
with amy schumer new year's eve we
[ __ ] murdered it in new orleans
now i'm here with [ __ ] joey diaz
who's that who's tomorrow [ __ ] johnny
depp son huh let me ask you luther
vandross who's next bro how big was your
carol levert how big was the uh
i think 2100 is at 2100 but she had
downs house from another place because
uh
um just because new orleans you're not
going to sell a lot of comedy tickets on
new year's eve it's a party city people
go out to drink you know
people get a drink half people only have
television sets brady chillin dude
new orleans miami
there's a couple cities that comedy has
always been a hard sell we've discussed
this before yeah that's why i was really
interested in that you know she's doing
new orleans
i kept thinking maybe she's doing a
riverboat casino i don't know if they
have those there well she does it
because she loves it she all of her
friends it's her favorite city so she
goes there every new year's eve anyway
so all of her friends go down there and
it's always a big party
it's an eight o'clock show a midnight
show it was eight o'clock show yeah
that's how pimps do it yeah you walk out
of that 10 30 there's no magic ball
pictures till 11 the car's leaving i
love you guys
see you in a year from now boom
yeah it was perfect man she cried i mean
it was fun man she's funny to be around
she's on your way up brother man she's
funny to be around that's good you're
working i feel great
i feel absolutely great i gotta slip jay
all right dude do your thing i'm gonna
be over at the colusa casino friday
january 6 and next weekend hilarious in
cleveland but let me talk to you about
something here
uh that you may uh
i want to talk to you about a smart way
turn extra money and get an extra 500
bonus driving with lyft
you know are you in between jobs are you
looking to earn extra money for your
kids college fund
are you going back to school yourself
are you thinking of writing the next
american novel
i mean there's got to be something
you're seeking alternative funding for a
new startup
listen here's what we're doing there's
other ride sharing apps out there but
lib streets that drive is right
it's a flexible way to make extra money
anytime from nearly anywhere all you
need is a car lift drivers can make up
to 35 an hour and get started is just a
tap away you can drive mornings nights
weekends
just flip into driver mode and start
making money plus lyft drivers can end
tips right from the app those apps
add up fast all right and you don't have
to wait for days or weeks to get paid
you could cash out instantly once you've
made 50
thanks to express pay it all adds up
driving with lyft is super flexible it
allows you to keep 100 of your tips and
it's always there when you need extra
cash
sign up today
at lyft.com
joey and right now
lyft has a special offer for our
listeners you'll get 500
a new driver bonus after you complete
100 rides within 30 days go to lyft.com
slash joey today and start making extra
money and get your 500
new driver bonus who's better than uncle
joey i got your ass out there pimping
driving cutting [ __ ] off on
lift again go to lyft.com stop sitting
there you [ __ ] mook your grandmother
died left you a nice car and you're
sitting there eating pizza and you're
giving a [ __ ] about who's the who's the
[ __ ] kid's father on maury go to
lyft.com right now is that what it is
lee yes sir go to lyft.com right now
slash joey
and start making money and get your 500
bonus
right now
how's that one for you joey's getting
your [ __ ] jobs huh
how bad is your life when uncle joey's
getting your job so here's another thing
guys you own a business you're looking
for the right people
it's tough to get right people
if i didn't like lee i'd be looking for
the right people but i love lee you know
what i'm saying amen but he doesn't
train
he's getting better he's growing check
in with ollie boss he already has my
back alibaba
alibis in australia holly boss
boss knows all no he doesn't but listen
let me tell you something people you
know i love you's all you got a business
you want to get some good people
it's a new year which means you want a
fresh start for your business and a
great year starts with making great
hires but posting your job in one place
isn't enough to find quality candidates
if you want to find the perfect hire you
need to post your job on all
the top job sites and now
you can with zip recruiter you can jump
start your hiring in 2017
post your job to 200 plus job sites
including social media networks like
facebook and twitter
and all with a single click
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates rolling to zip
recruiters easy to use interface
no juggling emails or calls to your
office quickly screen candidates rate
them and hire the right person
quickly find out today why zip recruiter
has been used over a million businesses
and right now my listeners can post jobs
on zip recruiter
for free by going to zip recruiter.com
church that's ziprecruiter.com
church one more time
go post your your job for free
to jo what is it ziprecruiter.com
church once again one more time try it
for free go to ziprecruiter.com
church that
ziprecruiter.com slash church
amen bro lisa spraying out his face dude
what are you laughing about literally
you [ __ ] monster can i drop my date
my dayton joe your what my date's gonna
drop whatever you want my brother i'm
gonna drop this for the next three weeks
i'm gonna drop this hot batch of
universe on you guys i'm gonna be in uh
all these are american all-american
dates bruh trump won't let me out the
country son you know how we doing it
uh february january 26th through 29th
i'll be in virginia beach at the funny
bone who goes to the beach in the winter
this mfa uh february 2nd through 4th
i'll be at chicago out in schaumburg
illinois at the improv february 22nd
through 25th i'll be at comedy work
south
so get in there get your nuts hard huh
bring your hard ass nut sack in there
and let's do net let's do it right huh
bring some [ __ ] on lee i guess i'll
i'll bring the hard nuts up okay right
on bro
but joey i want to thank you so much man
i love you bro you know that love you
too thank you for coming on i got [ __ ]
up tonight that those stars and that
truck and i was unlike other people
who you know haven't prayed overnight
he's hitting that squeal that beautiful
lee squeal man yeah yeah you two lee
great to be here with you man i really
appreciate it yeah everything's gonna be
great thank you for
listening to the church you know i love
you to all my heart if you're around
this friday
kalusa casino it's a fun time
myself and my man steve
d
simone you know what i'm saying i love
him stay black people have a great night
oh great day happy new year once again
do your thing write your goals do your
push-ups
it's all going to be beautiful all right
stay black
love you bro
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
this
town
[Music]
foreign
[ __ ]
so
[Music]
you